foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
yes sir we are here we are here my man
Michael Ritter is in the building Ryan
producer Ryan is here NBA is back it's
been back guys NBA has been back and we
are talking
NBA let's first talk about the three by
two if you guys don't know at home the
three by two is two three pointers in
the first three minutes they're now
offering it for every game they're
offering it for every game of friends
over there at fanduel's often for every
game
producer Ryan Michael Ritter talk to me
which one of which one which three by
two do you guys like today
well I mean when I look at this list
Greg there's there's one game that has
the best three-point shooter of all time
in it and it sounds pretty chalky to say
but the number I peeked at the number
earlier for that Warrior sentence minus
110. for the three by two in a Steph
Curry game and a Devin Booker game I'll
tell you I'm taking more of your sons
for that
Michael Ritter's walking with the
Warriors Sons because they are Shooters
all around in that game I I mean just
look around the floor there is Shooters
Ryan talked to us
that's why you thinking bro uh uh the
I'll just play Devil's Advocate and be a
contrarian because why not and let's do
Mass pelicans and we are getting a worse
number with it so why not
worst number worst three-point Shooters
but we'll eat it why not
Ryan's Ryan's in a why not mood I guess
why not you know what I mean I am no
explanation behind it
we also got a boost for you guys we got
a special boost for you guys last week
we hit on the Boost if you guys did not
know
now you know we it this week the Boost
Devin Booker 25 plus points
and Stephen Curry to shoot four
three-pointers we're boosting it from
plus 115 up to plus 200 you guys digging
this one
oh absolutely and I think like we'll
talk a lot about this game coming up
because you and I both have a specific
side in this one but if you're just a
basketball fan tonight and want to watch
maybe the arguably the best regular
season game so far I should throw a
little plus 200 on this this is a
outstanding boost to see some Steph
Curry hit four threes and Devin Booker
to go off hey man this is a great one
for me we're not saying go put your
mortgage on it just you know
let's sprinkle it a little bit no skin
in the game oh yeah throw some love
watch the game in a different way cheer
for both teams I guess here we go but
hey let's get started let's get into the
show six bets we love Michael Ritter
you are the guy you are the man today
producer Ryan
we're going to send you back to the chat
you go we're going to sing you back to
do what you love to do is talk to the
people uh drop your bets in the chat and
we'll talk about as many as we can
Ritter it is time it is time brother
that you got 45 seconds on the clock
and we're gonna start that right now
let's get straight to it
all right well first of all this is an
honor to be on the show I've been a fan
for a long time but I'm ready to talk
some NBA and let's get it started with
the game that you're looking most
forward to tonight I'm looking forward
most forward to tonight I have the
Warriors plus one and a half tonight
against the Phoenix Suns I really like
this bet tonight and for many many
reasons but for me the suns are a team
that are kind of I was trying to think
of like a sun setting I'm a little
worried about this Sun's team and I
don't worry about this Warriors team at
all I think they're humming right now
the only things I do worry about are
they have played the Lakers and the
Kings so far so this will be an up Step
Up in competition but Steph Curry better
than Chris Paul Chris Paul gets the
point God thing all the time there's not
many of these rounds left between Steph
and CP3 I'm rolling steps tonight and
the Warriors hey Ritter I I had to give
you the little timer thing uh producer
whispered in my ear told me to give you
a hard time because it looked like you
were nervous but I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding uh but yo love the pick
absolutely love the pick you were on
time also you lost some time at the
beginning bro the producer whispered in
my ear he whispered in my ear you were
nervous because you lost like four or
five seconds at the beginning because
you were saying that you were happy to
be here so you know what I might give
you four to five seconds more for this
next pick so you know what I'm saying I
love the first pick absolutely love the
first pick Golden State Warriors
actually let me talk to producer Ryan
before we go to your next play producer
Ryan come back in here talk to me talk
to Michael Ritter what are the people in
the chat talking about
uh I love being the voice of the haters
here so that that's what I'm going to
continue to do uh we've got Adrian Amayo
saying suckers are betting on the
Warriors
um okay he's not directly calling you a
sucker but it is an indirect it is it he
kind of is uh Fresh Prince
the 1986 saying mav's gonna run the
pills tonight
c-m-h-o-l Sons money line is a lock and
he has included five lock emojis so
but not six not six not six I feel like
that's saying something I feel like
that's saying something
if you really believed in it you'd put
six lock emojis that is what they're
saying that is what they're saying
and then Nick j saying might just go
dubs money line instead of taking the
points
a fair observation I'm a big if they're
gonna give you the one and a half just
take it just to be safe just to be safe
who knows even in the NBA
even in the NBA okay I know they're not
18 year olds like college basketball but
I'm gonna I'll take the one and a half
Fair hey my man Michael Ritter likes to
play safe
I like it he likes to play as safe hey
one bet down five more to go producer
Ryan we're going to send you back to the
chat go talk to the people uh let's go
Ritter you got 45 seconds on the clock
let's go all right I won't wax
poetically about this show anymore we'll
just get right to it and you might like
this Greg but probably not I'm going
with a player prop tonight Draymond
Green under seven and a half points now
you see that number and you're very
seven and a half you can't score eight
points Draymond Green doesn't need to
score eight points tonight Draymond
Green needs to facilitate the ball he
needs to play defense he needs to get it
to his Shooters on his team Steph Curry
Klay Thompson he needs to move the ball
around and play defense and that's what
he'll do tonight Draymond is in this
part of his career or scoring points
just doesn't matter
he will get the wide open look he will
make the extra pass he will go to the
basket and flip it out to the Splash
Brothers on the three he does not need
to score eight points tonight he won't
score eight points tonight it'll be
under that Draymond under seven and a
half points tonight
you got anything else Ritter I'm giving
you more seconds you got anything else
about Draymond or is that it no I'll
just thank you for having me on the show
again thanks Craig
I love it Draymond under seven and a
half oh Ritter
as a warrior fan we like to see Draymond
score that usually means we win games
but uh Draymond will be Draymond and
Draymond likes to play defense he likes
to facilitate that ball around he likes
to find those Shooters so I'm I'm riding
with you bro I I'm sending good vibes
your way for the second play now we got
four more four more plays
let's get to this third one Michael
Ritter
all right so we have four NBA games
tonight and I gotta get to six picks and
this one's gonna be really ugly and some
of you may never even heard of this
player before but I am a huge fan I'm
headed to the Thunder Clippers game
tonight and I am taking Trey man over 15
and a half points I'm a big Trey man man
uh the thunder tonight are not having
Josh giddy play they might have shea
gilders Alexander play now he has now
moved up to possible for the game I
don't think if he plays he'll play much
and somebody has to score on this team
and Trey man is a score if you've
watched Thunder basketball like me who's
a I'm a big fan of tanking basketball
Trey man is a star in tanking basketball
right now yeah they're gonna have
somebody have to score tonight against
the Clippers I'm going with Trey man he
will be the big scorer tonight for that
Thunder team
that's who I'm rolling with
there it is Trey man my man Micah Ritter
is rocking with the over there if you
guys take a look at your screen take a
look to the right you see his picks go
to FanDuel go put it in
go Vibe with us Michael Ritter that's
three picks we got three more to go
talk to him
right to me now he did a couple players
did a couple player props we're gonna go
back to his side tonight we're gonna go
to the first game on the NBA TNT game
tonight and obviously I'm a huge
Pelicans guy but without Williamson
without Ingram and now without herb
Jones I cannot not take the Mavs minus
five and a half tonight I know it's a
square bet I understand when all the
players are on the other side I just
think five and a half is too small of a
number they might be able to hang a
little bit at the beginning of this game
but I feel the Luca night tonight I
think this is going to be one of those
national televised game Luca is the MVP
front runner right now and to get a game
on national TV or early in the week not
not a lot of other games tonight eyes
will be on Luca I think Luca goes off
tonight and I think the Mavs covered
that five and a half especially with an
injured Pelicans team in New Orleans so
rolling with the match tonight I'm sure
you like that one Greg rocking with the
maps I do like that you mentioned all
the injuries that's happening with that
Pelican roster
um this has me skeptical embedding them
right now they just have me skept going
betting them
Mavericks minus five and a half my man
Michael Ritter has spoken you guys make
sure you guys
go check it out ride with them
Michael Ritter let's move on to your
next pick we got four down two more to
go
so I mentioned that I'm a big Pelicans
guy this year don't like him tonight but
the other team I'm a big big fan of and
have a future on is the Detroit Pistons
and I like them tonight at five and a
half getting five and a half against the
Washington Wizards I love this Pistons
team this is a new look team they are
not in the tanking realm this is a team
that could compete for a playing game
this year I love what they've done
Kate Cunningham and Jaden Ivey are going
to be the next big combo guard situation
in the NBA and I really like them
tonight especially because the Wizards
again
I think they're actually a team that
should be trying to tank I don't really
like what they've built I'm a brad Beale
guy St Louis proud he needs to get the
hell off that team and go play somewhere
else I really like the business tonight
catching five and a half
there it is Michael Ritter said he likes
the Pistons catching five and half you
mentioned you have a future on them
gotta know what what future did you
place on the Detroit Pistons I hope it's
not Championship it's not a championship
bet don't worry I took them over 29 and
a half wins this year and they already
got one so I just need 29 more we're
just rooting for 30 wins for our pistons
and I think that they can get to that
this year I I really really like this
team there it is Scoops you heard it
here uh we gotta check in with producer
Ryan because producer Ryan's been in the
chat and I know he's been in there
looking and reading reacting to the
haters to the people that's showing us
love but producer Ryan talk to us
what they talking about in the chat well
read her real quick the last time that
we bet the Pistons you know what
happened they got cooked by the New York
Yankees by the Knicks man it's all right
it happens it was in the garden baby you
know things weird things happen there
Nixon Wizards might be the exact same
team who knows I disagree okay Fabian
can too uh Sharon the Luca love say Luca
double double and Dallas to win uh so
parlaying that uh we've got Cool Hand
Luke saying debug for 40 tonight
uh Bear Down book at least 30. Fabian
Cantu book over 29 and a half PR betting
fademan green
paid one green that's really good
that made me laugh uh cam Sai Curry four
plus threes uh and then Fabian Cantu
back in the chat saying Ritter giving
out face
okay I needed at least one negative
comment it couldn't all be positive
that's true hey hey
Good Vibes only here Good Vibes only
Ritter you're not giving out face
brother I will back you up you're not
giving out Fades but let's go we need
this last pick we got five picks
we need the last Pig the people want to
know I want to know which pick are we
not fading
that's right and we're writing and I
mentioned it before Jade and Ivy tonight
points rebounds and assists over 24 and
a half Jayden Ivy's points rebound and
assists have hit in every Pistons game
this year I am a huge huge Jaden Ivy fan
I think he's going to be NBA Rookie of
the Year and his matchup tonight I
mentioned this his primary Defender is
going to be Brad Beale God love Brad
Beale he's a St Louis Legend he can
score the basketball he is tissue paper
defensively and I think Kate Cunningham
and Jaden Ivey are going to expose him
tonight on the basketball court Jaden
Ivy can't speak highly enough about him
I actually think he was almost
underrated whenever he was at Purdue
don't think they quite used him properly
in Matt painter's system we could talk
college basketball another time but I'm
rolling with Jade and Ivy tonight to
have a really nice night tonight against
the Washington Wizards and I'm of course
taking them to cover as well
hey you left some time on the clock
right there you left some time on the
clock right there Michael Ritter but
hold on so you're saying Bradley Bill
you know your big Bradley Bill lover
you're from St Louis Bradley blue you
know his ties to St Louis
so you mean to tell me you're calling
Bradley Bill barbecue chicken on defense
as a town famous for barbecue uh yes I
am I I have to say that about my friend
Brad Beale Bradley Beal he prefers to be
called Bradley I'm sorry
there it is my man right Michael Ritter
I need barbecue chicken in the comments
y'all go find it gifts go barbecue
chicken is in the comments uh let's talk
let's talk to my man producer Ryan who
is in those comments he's in the chat
producer Ryan
there probably is is there barbecue
chickens in there are they talking about
my man Michael Ritter's points rebounds
and assists with uh Jaden Knight now
they're talking about the points
rebounds assists of course we've got
will Gregson here saying uh Ritter this
Pistons propaganda has to stop uh he he
also wants to be on the show because he
says he's got some locks but then we'll
just be getting Nets propaganda which is
significantly worse
um yeah so we don't need any of that
also a quick note on the uh pra for
Jaden Ivey his first game which was what
two three games ago the pra was 14 and a
half so that's jumped up 10. that's
pretty nuts like you said it's hitting
every single game
um we've got Jay Matos asking Pistons
money line what do you guys think
I don't hate it I I consider putting it
in here I think this is going to be a
close game tonight and I just again I
think five and a half I would put this
game more of like a Wizards by two kind
of game but if you're a Pistons fan I I
I'm all about if you're gonna believe in
your team uh go ahead and roll with the
money line because I I I I've said it
I'm a big believer in this team and and
put my money where my mouth is for sure
there you go uh we've got a Gutierrez
asking is this the same guy who said to
fade NY teams for football last week
that would be Sam fraudman
I put those videos out there but I
didn't say it
slander slam is the BR betting
Guru he's the
BR betting and we will respect that
man's name when it comes to that uh
Michael Ritter's just dropped his six
Best Bets take a screenshot of this go
bet those
because my man's about to be winning
today I can see it Michael Ritter I'm
sending good vibes your way all right
you guys see at the top of the screen it
says coming up Greg's pick yes now it is
time it is time
but make sure before we get to my pick
you guys keep dropping your locks in the
chat because at the end of the show me
and Michael readers we're going to
return the favor to you guys you guys
are sitting here talking about our picks
we're going to return the favor to you
guys uh before I get to my pick
are there any barbecue chickens in the
comments I need to know that right I
need to know if people listen to me we
do have some barbecue chickens hold on I
got Fabian Cantu smoking barbecue
tonight uh
we had a few uh Jason Jason gzz barbecue
chicken with three ends we've got
yep nope sorry yeah they're listening
yeah they're listening I just want to
make sure they're listening because
we're about to get down to the
nitty-gritty gritty I was looking at
some props with my
woman we were surfing the FanDuel page
uh and uh I came across
something very very interesting in the
in the combos page in the combos page on
uh FanDuel I saw my man Andrew Wiggins
and the Golden State Warriors to win
sitting at plus
290 the player performance combinations
however you want to call it player
performances we got Andrew Wiggins 18
points of Golden State Warriors
to win plus 290 and I absolutely love
this one my man Andrew Wiggins is
already averaging
22.3 points per game he scored 24 23 and
20. meaning today he only needs to get
18. I like that we're just connecting
the dots there also I'm gonna say it
right now Andrew Wiggins is the second
best player on this Golden State
Warriors team
he's the second best player on his going
to start going on this Golden State
Warriors team we saw his impact during
the finals we saw his impact during the
playoff run how important he is to this
team not only on the offensive side but
the defense of side
the Golden State Warriors
I think they win today I think they go
out to Phoenix and they get to win
Houston I mean Phoenix has been playing
ah they've been playing The Warriors
also have been playing and but I think
after last game them giving up almost a
20-point lead against the Sacramento
Kings they're going to come out with in
this game with a sense of urgency and I
think that they're going to get the job
done so you guys go look at this one go
look at this one study it study it and
then put the bed in my man Andrew
Wiggins plus 18 plus points and the
Golden State Warriors to win it's plus
money and I like it Ryan does the chat
like it well you're moving lines Greg I
don't know if you saw as you're talking
it moved down to Plus 285. there it is
they know something they hate me sharp
action is on the plate
is on the play and you guys seen it live
you guys just seen it live so do what
you do go do what you do there you go uh
the chat though a Gutierrez says that's
nice but I think Wiggins cuts it close
so I there's a butt in there
you cut it I don't know it the ambiguous
that that chat
um we've got
Fabian Cantu Greg is the goat
get some Greg love in there uh B Cameron
yes sir Wiggins been balling
um Jason gzz Greg is the lock master
got a lot of great we got a lot of Greg
love in here some barbecue chickens as
well they're just catching they're just
catching up
I need more barbecue chickens in the
comments uh hey do they have do you see
plays in the comments because I feel
like it's time
for us to to grade some of their plays
we we got my place we got Michael Ritter
play well we got my play I only got one
I gave you guys one Michael Ritter gave
us six he gave us six God should have
been paying attention
do they have any plays in the chat Ryan
are they saying anything
that's catching your eye yeah so we've
got Marco Rojas saying Luca 30 plus
points Christian Wood 10 plus rebounds
and the Dallas Mavericks to win the game
parlay
yeah wow I want to want to know what
those odds are I actually kind of like
that
talk to him
I really like that too that sounds
pretty similar to a same game parlay
that I cooked up earlier today and all
of us helped cook up so I really like it
I think when you're looking at
especially Luca overs for tonight he's
averaging almost near damn near 30 a
game so again I said it I expect a huge
night from Luke tonight national
televised game MVP front runner you have
a depleted Pelicans team and the rest of
those legs like I'm a huge Christian
Wood fan I I'm really curious to see how
he'll work on this Mavs team I know he's
played a few games but when we saw him
at the tail end of his Pistons career we
saw him in Houston he could just take
over games he's and he's confident
that's the biggest thing about Christian
Wood he's a confident I wouldn't say
cocky confident player um if if Luca has
a bad shooting night for some reason I
think Christian Wood's a really fun
player to throw into a lot of same game
parlays and a lot of those kinds of just
picks in general because I think he's a
special player I will say
go ahead yeah I was gonna say I will say
I ran the numbers that parlay that we
just talked about that was dropped in
Plus 575. whoo there it is
Ritter you mentioned it yeah Scoops
scoops
and we got to do that that's a new thing
bro yeah the comments give us Scoops
we're Scoops yes go ahead Rick go ahead
Ryan
I was just gonna say Ritter mentioned
the same game parlay we had cooked up
let's just take it there we've got a
same game parlay
on FanDuel we got a nice little Banner
here all you gotta do hit bet now
boom plus 417. here's what it is Dallas
Mavericks money line Luka doncic 25 plus
points Spencer Dinwiddie 15 plus points
and Christian Wood
like Ritter said a fun player to add in
eight plus rebounds those four legs plus
417 tailless on FanDuel
right there on the banner easy one one
click that's all you got to do that's it
just go on FanDuel and click it and you
can ride along with us and get rich plus
417. I like it I like it and we were in
the lab cooking this one up so I I like
this one a lot uh
Ryan
talk to me just just give me do you see
any more barbecue chickens in the
comments is this the barbecue chickens
in the comments I'm I'm on three
separate screens right now Greg so I'm
I'm trying to figure it out everyone's
got their plays up in this chat right
now uh not too many barbecue chickens
that's perfect I love their place
because it's time for me and Ritter to
grade some more of their plays let's
let's let's return the favor let's
return
let's return what they give to us Ritter
let's let's let's let's give it back to
them
I'm gonna do some good vibes though
because this Good Vibes are only over
here so Ryan run through some plays and
uh me and Ritter were great those plays
okay the amount I will say the amount of
Luca double double in Dallas to win that
has been dropped to this chat absurd we
talked about it before so no need to go
back but that is like the most popular
play in the chat uh A.D Harris Lou dork
over 16 and a half points
ooh it's 16 and a half okay yeah
I got I got my letter grades here Greg I
don't know if you want to go first but I
can give a grade to that
say it one more time Ryan I gotta think
about that one that one's tough one more
time just give me some time to think Lou
Dort over 16 and a half points
give it a b
give it a B I could see him getting it I
can see him getting the same thing you
mentioned that earlier Ritter you talked
about it what's happening out there so I
can see him trying to score the ball
more today you know
I'm a huge Lou Dort fan I don't know if
you guys have followed the Velveeta
cheese Twitter account but they're
famous for tweeting about lewd Dort as
well um so maybe not a big as fan as
Velveeta cheese uh but I'm I'm a big
blue dork guy but I I'm picking Trey man
to be the scorer tonight over Luke that
doesn't mean he can't break that or or
go over that pick but uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna give it a B I still like it but
I'm gonna say Trey man's the the leading
scorer tonight for the Oklahoma City
Thunder
okay we've got Ryan branscrum Thunder
plus nine
whoa okay
okay whoa
my generator testing you
I'm going back I'm going back as as a
former B student myself I'm going to
stick with the letter grade that I know
the best it almost made the show it
almost made the six bets for me tonight
just because this Thunder team likes to
hang around and if you were betting
against the spread last NBA season that
was a big trend of Thunder where anytime
you got near that double digit Mark
Thunder were a pretty safe bet to cover
that spread uh I think the Clippers are
without Paul George tonight so it'll be
a kawaii show I I don't I don't hate it
I didn't it almost made the show but I'm
gonna just I'm gonna stick with Trey man
props Tonight I'm Gonna Roll with him
but I'm a big thunder guy and will be
for probably a long time
you beat me to the scoops
online I'm looking at the line movement
and it seems like the sharps are on the
thunder so I like it that's why I gave
it a b it was to start play the sharp
play Thunder at home
yeah and if you ever want to know the
percentage of bets uh on a specific side
on FanDuel there's a tab for that 54 of
the bets are on the Clippers tonight at
minus eight and a half okay so there it
is that's for the people that like the
fade the public yes sir right that was a
scoop brother that was a scoop that was
scooping yeah we keep scooping all right
Chris and tone Chris Paul over nine and
a half assists
uh I think today is going to be a day
that we just
continue to give bees
I think I'll go the opposite way here
I'll go I'll go see just because it kind
of goes against my pick for tonight uh
and also
nine assists I'm I'm leaning more
towards the not double digits tonight
I think we always we always think like
oh that's easy for him but like
FanDuel knows these numbers very well
they set them for a very good reason
they're they're smart people over there
I think nine assists for Chris Paul
tonight so I I think he goes under but
I'll give it a c I'll give it a c i was
a b and c student so
okay I'm I'm gonna work hard my promise
to the chat is I'm gonna get them in a
one of these days we have tough teachers
in here so Mr DJ blue Mavs versus
Pelicans over to 18 and a half barbecued
chicken I added in the last part to try
to appeal to Greg
so they're going with the over on the
total
over 218 and a half
hmm
Ritter
how you feeling about that one what was
this username again Mr DJ blue
Mr DJ blue
I have to give you a b I'm sorry I just
I worry about the Pelicans being able to
score with this I don't worry about the
Mavs 218 it feels like a pretty good
number I'm thinking more like a two yeah
I I think it's I think it's I think it's
short of that but I like the play I like
that you know if Zion and bi were
playing I think this is a really high
scoring game but even when the Pelicans
have a really good defense I know herb
Jones isn't playing tonight but I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to just
roll with a B on this one I'm sorry Mr
DJ blue
oh
f
oh he said over right over 218. Eddie
added barbecue chicken
under
you heard it here first Ritter talked
about the injuries like he said if like
he just talked about the injuries if
they everybody was in the lineup then
okay yeah that's easy but the fact that
we don't know if they're going to jail
tonight because they got guys in the
lineup that's probably not you know
accustomed to starting or whatever
I really hope DJ blue keeps watching to
be honest I had the faith I had the
faith the the chat like they fade Ritter
they faded Raiders they were talking
about Sam I had to return it like I I
got to be that guy sometimes to return
the favor you know it's just brutal
right after I promised them in a you
give them an F so we're gonna go one
more we're gonna give we're gonna give
the chat one more try uh also more
Scoops uh no shy gilligas Alexander or
Josh giddy tonight for the thunder so
the plus nine will be tough
so it's official that SGA is not playing
Now official according to the chat the
chat has cooked me before so we'll we'll
do our own research on the side and then
we'll and then we'll see uh Trey man
Trey man Trey man there you go all right
so last one
if this doesn't get an A from Greg I
don't know what will Scott Lakers Jordan
Poole over 15 and a half points
he's been struggling Jesus
we can't win
you know what I'll give him an a gray
can think about it I'll give him a name
it feels like a pity a
no it's not okay hey I got plenty of
pityas back in the day Mr Scott Laker or
whatever your name is I we love Jordan
pool
he's been struggling a little bit uh
so he can break out of it break out of
it get into a rhythm so
I give him a b because Jordan pool is
one of those players that can literally
go off like you know what I mean in a
quarter yeah he can literally go off on
the quarter so it'll be
all right wow promises delivered then
promises make promises delivered there
it is hey I had but we had fun we had
fun I mean Michael Ritter gave us six
picks that are gonna hit you guys got my
Sharp play if you guys go look at the
numbers it is a sharp play and the line
moved on the show shark play and hit and
then we had fun grading you guys picks
also make sure you guys check out the
odds boost that we boosted because last
week it hit this week
I'm giving I'm sending Good Vibes I
think it's gonna hit again
my name is Greg ivory from Michael
Ritter and producer Ryan we
out of here Ace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]